professor Brailsford a lot of people
talk about von Neumann architecture and
we've talked about Babbage we've talked
about chewing who was von Neumann
we've done a lot about chewing we've
done a fair bit about Babbage in the
generation earlier in fact a lot of
people I guess in the english-speaking
world would regard Turing in some way as
being the father of computing it came up
with this very important result in the
mid thirties about what was computable
and as we now know he to his credit it
wasn't at all afraid to burn himself at
soldering iron and try to create
hardware which he did at Bletchley Park
during the war so yes if he's the father
if Babbage was the grandfather and if a
the Countess of Lovelace was the
great-aunt
then who on earth was John von Neumann
and why is he mentioned alongside during
well right early-out so let's say John
von Neumann was the impossibly talented
impossibly charismatic very wealthy
uncle to computing it was he that in the
mid 1940s in a way made it all happen by
the force of his own personality and
kept it not just in an enclosed
community but encouraged all those who
wanted to build general-purpose
computers to come along to this summer
school and do it but that really I guess
is in the future it's where we've got to
get to in the von Neumann story but yes
you're quite right Shawn to say that one
of the first phrases that almost any
computer scientist hears about is the
von Neumann architecture for computers
which to a large extent we still follow
even now all of 160 50 years later so
we've mentioned dead sack before we'll
be coming back to mention this very
important early computer again but it is
a von Neumann machine and all it's
saying is it's very simple to build a
computer you need a store or memory as
it's more commonly called nowadays to
hold your instructions and your data you
need a
control unit often called a CPU now and
you need an arithmetic capability the
ALU the arithmetic and logic unit again
many of you will know in modern chips
those two are often combined into what
we just call the CPU chip nowadays and
you need input devices of various sorts
leading back to people's telly types
input/output devices for backup storage
disk and so on you need to be able to do
input and output so there it is it's
just one two three four five boxes that
is the von Neumann architecture and it's
very very similar today there was a big
debate at the time about that store that
memory shouldn't you for safety's sake
put the instructions of your program in
a different sort of memory to your data
wouldn't it be safer to do that and
better in some ways on the other hand
clearly if you've got a good memory
technology that works the temptation
might be just to put them in separate
areas of that same technology and try
and take some sort of precaution about
them not interfering with each other in
edsac the only way to get into a
subroutine and get back out of it again
was to override part of your program
instructions let's just return back to
this incredible character john von
neumann how does he fit in alongside
Alan Turing well like I said he's the
older impossibly talented uncle did
cheering of von Neumann know each other
oh yes they did they were both basically
trained as mathematicians mano a man
it's hard to know where to begin and
where to end
you can't exaggerate enough about how
good he was he was Hungarian and his
Hungarian name where they give surnames
first was I think no mananas
his father was very very wealthy and
when one was quite young the family
became ennobled in Hungary became
basically at the level of Baron
hereditary Baron I think
over here Jana was very talented he was
a childhood prodigy he could divide one
eight digit number by another eight
digit number in a fraction of a second
when he was aged about 6 he loved
history he was a multi-talented polymath
he easily came top of the class he
effortlessly took in detail and that's
the first thing that all of his
mathematics contemporaries said about
him was his sheer speed of picking up
new ideas and seeing the ramifications
of them so he was notorious even as a
teenager and as a maths undergrad he did
his early education I think up to PhD
level in Budapest he almost naturally
ended up at a place we mentioned before
in connection with girdle and Hilbert
I'm talking of course about getting an
University in Germany so Norman janosh
makes the journey via a PhD to becoming
effectively the research assistant
so the superstar David Hilbert at
gutting them but because his family
being a noble's
he's not Janish Norman any more known in
Janos sorry he's johann von Neumann
impossibly talented Hilbert his
supervisor at a seminar given by by
Johnny
John Johan asked who his tailor was
because he's impossibly smart
pinstripe suit was just a complete
knockout so he was a legend almost the
moment he got there and did some
fabulously important work there it was
obvious that for somebody of his talents
he was going to get a full professorship
very quickly indeed I think it became
impatient waiting for it to happen at
any German university so in the late
thirties 37 38 somewhere around there
anyway he got an offer from Princeton in
New Jersey and that was I don't know
very timely it's all fitted in together
very well as part of his tours of Europe
giving seminars and on his way to
Princeton I think he met churring in the
mid thirties in Cambridge because he
gave seminars there
and I think a lot of mutual respect grew
up I mean obviously curing being in or
von neumann wouldn't be so exceptional
but after that 1936 paper of Turing's
about decidability following on from
girdle and all that von Neumann rated
Turing there was no question of how that
this was evidenced by the fact you will
recall those of you seen my previous
videos that Turing also took a
sabbatical and worked with Alonzo Church
at Princeton
well von Neumann was there by that time
one was such a superstar they not only
made him professor and mathematics of
Princeton at an absurdly early age
probably about 30 something like that
but some of you were recalled right next
door to Princeton about a mile and a
half across the meadows is the Institute
for Advanced Studies which have been
endowed in the early 1930s by a
multi-millionaire and this really was
the ultimate Club to be invited to join
you've got to be of the quality of
Einstein who accepted the invitation
Hermann vile one of the founders of
quantum mechanics girdle we know about
girdle girdle was invited to just come
to IAS Institute of immense visit
princess stay as long as you like yes
you're a professor everything found food
accommodation a lot all we want is to
have the greatest minds here von Neumann
was offered a professorship in that
community I think at age 35 maybe
slightly younger unbelievably young he'd
hardly been a prince in a year or two as
an ordinary mathematics professor
everybody thought this is a truly
phenomenal person he reminded many
people of absolute superstars like
Newton Gauss Euler Einstein Hilbert
himself even that me early to mid
thirties they could see that potential
in him there so yes Turing visits
Princeton in 1938 worked with Alonzo
Church but also of course had frequent
interactions
monoi man and then came the big question
if you recall for Alan Turing should I
return to England and do my patriotic
duty according to Andrew Hodges
definitive biography of chirring
chirring father was all for curing
staying in Princeton you know keep out
the war gets a prestigious mathematic
job and that was underlined by the fact
that von neumann offered during a job he
basically said Turing would you like to
be my research assistant at the
Institute for Advanced Studies now
tareka see straightaway that just would
just make you as a mathematician you
were invited by the great Fontenoy Minh
to be his research assistant is only
problem was I think first of all I think
Alan Turing did feel a certain
patriotism in wanting to come home and
do his bit there was also the worry if
there's at that time von Norman had not
properly got into computing he'd not
turned his considerable talents to
considering it and for the research
assistantship he wanted Alan Turing to
do quantum mechanics another of von
neumann's great love and I don't think
cheering was keen on that because he
knew from experience at Cambridge where
he'd tried doing mathematical physics it
really wasn't his arena at all so he
politely declined with great things came
back to England and the rest if you like
is more or less history now there's
Johnny as he'd now become johann von
Neumann speaker of four five languages
including Italian and English once he'd
transferred from getting on to Princeton
wanted to become the all-american genius
so he was in a more formal occasions he
was just John von Neumann but to his
friends he was Johnny I you counties
graduates enough I mean his wife said he
can count everything but calories he was
fond of food and drink the champagne
parties the glitz the glamour the
girlfriends good old Johnny he
absolutely was the antithesis of the
Shire mathematician he was all
encompassing and everyone who met him
was just
by how he could see his way through
problems in no time flat and just do
impossible things and so he was there in
a very very nice position Institute for
Advanced Studies even before the
Americans joined the war but he stayed
there throughout the war but being who
he was he was endlessly in demand to be
a consultant and most famously along
with people like J robert Oppenheimer he
was one of the consultants employed on
the Manhattan Project the atomic bomb in
the hydrogen bomb but he was used by the
army the US Navy the Air Force
everybody wanted Johnny as their
consultant and this even included as the
war developed the facts that one of the
earliest computers which we have
mentioned in a previous video was
University of Pennsylvania Moore School
of Engineering they helped develop the
ENIAC which if you remember was a vacuum
tube computer running on decimal
arithmetic and initially devoted to
gunnery trajectory calculations it was a
bit late in 1946 to be indirect
strategic using gunnery actually Johnny
who by this time of course was a
consultant to the Moore School devised a
way I think to turn any akin to being a
general purpose computer although it
wasn't a very efficient one and I
believe he used it for some calculations
relevant to the atomic bomb and all that
kind of thing the natural question
arising with everybody at the end of the
war went like this we all know or even
though it's top-secret at Bletchley Park
we have heard gentle rumors that
computers are being developed all over
the place and you've always got to say
are they special-purpose how they
general-purpose are they
binary are they decimal are they fully
electronic or are they electromechanical
and literally there must have been at
least a dozen machines around that
satisfied some of these criteria if you
ask Germans about who's the father
computing they say konrad zuse a-- he
developed electromechanical
machines look what you're incomplete and
calculated things but they never got
beyond electromechanical you get on to
electronic ones you get at enough some
fun berries electronic valve driven
thing special purpose though could solve
certain differential equations and even
Tommy flowers and Colossus we know
special purpose can decrypt any traffic
Lawrence cipher has it later become
known as so you've got everything
happening that if it's general-purpose
it's not yet electronic if it's
special-purpose it is electronic but we
want it to be general-purpose so at the
end of the war was the perfect time to
get everybody together and say look now
that the war's over we all want to find
the way to do it correctly to build
general-purpose probably binary base
because they're more reliable all
electronic digital computers how do we
do it
and who better to lead the charge and
run a summer school and be associated
with it then uncle Johnny of course and
the more school at Pennsylvania to their
great credit did this they decided that
the successor to ENIAC would be a thing
called Edie vac they said yeah it's
gonna take us three or four years to do
this but in the meantime here we are
1946 why not all of you all over the
world who are interested in the quest to
build general-purpose all electronic
digital computers probably based on the
binary system will hold a summer school
in the Moore School of Engineering 1946
welcome everybody did cheering go to it
he was I believe in that time of a
National Physical Laboratory in the UK
no he didn't
hated conferences did cheering he wasn't
a club herbal character couldn't stand
small talk classic
shy mathematician not at all live on
ointment right so Turing wasn't if you
like the UK representative there and one
wonders whether he would also been held
about by Bletchley Park and the Official
Secrets Act course he'd only just left a
few years before the representative from
the UK was somebody who was Turing's a
Zach contemporary they had both done
mathematics in the early 1930s at
Cambridge they had both got first-class
degrees did they get on not very well
but who's this other person his name is
maurice wilkes Morris Vincent Wilkes and
by the vagaries of job allocations
around about World War two he didn't end
up at Bletchley Park did Morris he ended
up in radar but he knew enough about
mathematics and electronics to be in a
good position to do I'll make a von
Neumann machine in the UK in the period
from about 1946 onwards but we better
stop there because Morris and his edsac
is an extra story
and this depends on the value being
fetched from there and I'm just going to
show this as an arrow here but the next
instruction load r2 from a see why
doesn't depend on anything